STARTING LINES TOP OF THE SCREEN
BROUGHT TO YOUcTAVISH.
HENRIQUE WITH TERRY.AL, THIS
HE'LL DELAY HIS SHOT.
TURNED OUT BY G
>> J.T.: SHOT, HE
SCOOORES!
POINTS IN 13 STRAIGHT
THROUGH THE SCREEN OF GIORDANO.
GRUBAUER NOT A LOT.
SHOT.
HE SCOOORES!
OH, THEY NEEDED THAT!
JADEN SCHWARTZ! IT IN.
SCHWARTZ SON AHE STICK OF GRUBA
RIGHT OFF THE FACEOFF.
MAHURA IS BROUGHT RIGHT BACK TO
HIM, HE WAIST NO TIME WITH IN F
THEYN,
CONTROLLING THE PUCK, DONATO
SEES THE PUCK GOING CYCLES OUT,
ALL THE WAY ACROSS
SCORES, IT LEAKS LEAKS
THROUGH THE BLOCKER SID THE TRI
EBERLE'S STICK, A QUICK ON AND
OFF.
NOT ENOUGH TIME FORLINDHOLM.
THEY HADT IT THERE YOU
JARED McCANN! FOREHAND, MAHURA
TURNING THE OTHER WAY, IT GOES
OFF THE BAR,
CRUISING RIGHT THROUGH THE SLOT.
KNOCKED DOWN BY McTAVISH.
ALEX WENNBERG. SHOT BY SHATTENK.
HERE COME THE KRAKEN, JADEN
SCHWARTZ WITH JORDAN  EARLY HERT
TROY TERRY WILL HIT IT, HIS
SECOND GOAL TONIGHT.STICK, MAKE
MISTAKE, KIND OF KNEW IF IT